[MUSIC]
Well hi Tony, it's so great to have you
here, thank you for being with us today.
You are one of the most celebrated and
most decorated business leaders in
Africa and I would posit the world.
So it's truly an honor to be able to
host you, at Stanford this afternoon.
>> Thank you very much
>> We watched a video earlier,
where we learned a little
bit about the foundation
which we'll speak about towards,
the later half of the interview.
But we saw there that
you're such a supporter and
such an advocate of entrepreneurship.
Which isn't really a surprise,
because your parents were entrepreneurs.
I'm curious to know,
how seeing them build businesses
at a young age influenced you and
impacted your journey.
>> I'm pleased and
honored to be with you all today.
Stanford, great university, and
a team from this pay
University visa dittany
Foundation lot before
the pandemic I think.
And I was quite impressed there on time.
[LAUGH] As part of the chaotic
traffic situation in Lagos.
And the research work
also very impressive.
So for me coming back here,
such as how they get in
pressure of your school.
Entrepreneurship is in my DNA,
I preach entrepreneurship,
I encourage entrepreneurship.
I also try to catalyze more
intrapreneurs in Africa,
because in my own life journey.
I've come to appreciate the significance,
the importance of entrepreneurship.
In transforming families in transforming
self, in transforming communities,,
in transforming country's societies for
humanity.
When we find out
the Tony Elumelu foundation.
It was driven by the need and urgency,
to help catalyze development in Africa,
the scale,
sustainable realizing for
that entrepreneurship is a way to that.
I was privilege, lucky, blessed to be
mentored in this journey
of entrepreneurship
first by my parents, especially my mom,
who was an entrepreneur, small scale.
But the lessons I imbibed, watching her,
supporting her,
continue to help me to date.
And it's also critical, in the message and
advice I give to young entrepreneurs.
I learned from her about hard work.
She was extremely hardworking at the time.
Today she's not on 94 and
she's she will cook for me.
>> [LAUGH].
>> As it sent her to come on pick food And
I'm like,
I have so many people to cook for me.
But that spirit in her remains so strong.
She was disciplined, and
I've come to realize that this journey
of entrepreneurship, this advantage,
entrepreneurship everything in life
discipline is critical for success.
He was extremely tenacious.
And I've come to see, and
I put it to, that the journey
entrepreneurship is not a linear journey,
is up and down.
But if you're tenacious and
resilient, you cross the finish line?
So those are part of the early
learners from my parents.
My mom, my dad, long ago told us and
and the, see my brain to date.
That if you earn $1,
if you're unable to save,
you any billion dollars you
will not save anything.
So that for me the first lesson and
capital formation,
capital formation starts from savings.
If you do not save,
you don't have money to invest.
If you don't invest,
you remain where you are.
And so these lessons have helped me
in this journey of entrepreneurship.
>> So lets fast forward a few years
,you graduate from university
with a Bachelors and
a Masters degree in Economics.
You then proceed to become one of the
youngest bank branch managers in Nigeria,
typically a job reserved for
people who are in their 50s or 60s.
You become the managing director one
of the biggest banks in Nigeria.
And then 2005 comes around,
and you're being asked to help
lead what becomes like the biggest
merger in Nigeria's corporate history.
What were some of the challenges
that you faced during that time?
And which leadership principles did you
stay rooted in as you were guiding this
process?
>> At the time quite a lot of challenges,
but
just to contextualize the won't stand it.
We took over a distressed bank,
cause a natural bank In 1987,
and in 2005, we met Standard Troz
Bank I United Bank of Africa.
But before the merger there was
an acquisition, standard was acquired and
significant interest in native
of Africa that were met.
And I emerged CEO, so
first I saw United above Africa as
almost 70 years old as an institution.
And kicked a set ways of doing things.
Then digital adoption was not so
strong, so
I think it took people
months to read males in.
And, in terms of service delivery,
those days,
the old generation banks were not so
strong on service delivery.
We were coming from a bank that was so
strong in service delivery and
technology, young people, etc.
So bank we size off less than 1800 people,
and
the United Bank of Africa
had over 12,000 staff.
These 1800 younger,
technologically advance,
and this other one older and
a very big blank.
That are not easy integrating
because as you see cooperate majors,
the legal combination is not the issue.
The difficult part is people integration,
the culture integration.
That is the top part and so as you can see
from history, most corporate institutions,
it takes so many years to
integrate people and culture.
And if you do not integrate people and
culture properly,
you lose the major value levers.
So we were mindful of this
I wanted to measure we,
we were able to match integrate.
And it's a financial institution that was
like you match the one customers don't
care whether, they want to be served
same institution they moved up.
Those are tough, integrating our people,
merging our people, merging cultures,
old culture state set in their ways and
a vibrant younger culture.
But there in lies the interesting
aspect of the combination of the job.
I say to people, my elder brother
who is seven years older than me,
he doesn't have gray hair.
I have my gray hair.
My gray hair started from
the merger because making it work,
serving your customers.
Making sure that everyone in
the universe of the institution,
which we had 428 branches at the time,
that it was same level
of service across board.
Customers of Standard Trust Bank that
were used to a certain level of service
delivery, you will not want them to come
to the new institution and have a drop.
So we just have to make sure
that we put our customers first.
That's why today in United Bank for
Africa,
which interestingly,
has grown from a one country
bank to a bank that operates
in 20 African countries,
with presence also in Paris,
London, recently Dubai.
And the only African bank that operate
in US as a deposit taking institution.
It started small, it's growing that big.
And that experience during the merger
continue to guide what we do,
especially how we prioritize our customers
and how we prioritize our people.
So I would say the biggest lesson
from that combination was with
making our people,
integrating our people, our culture.
I was realizing that,
especially in the service sector,
where you sell intangibles, so to speak.
It is very important that your core army,
your workforce,
that they are fully aligned,
totally integrated,
and positively mobilized, and motivated.
If you lack this, you can't make progress.
And those lessons from the early days,
resilience, hard work,
discipline, staying focused,
prioritizing people,
have all helped us in creating
today's United Bank for Africa.
>> And as you mentioned, you all were
able to do that very successfully.
You expanded from being a single country
bank to one that operates in 20 countries
in Africa.
And then has an impact and influence and
reach in other countries as well.
Many of us are interested in working
in emerging markets or are building,
developing products or
services for emerging markets, or
one emerging market, to begin with.
And I'm curious to know, how do you
evaluate which markets to enter when
you were expanding United Bank of Africa?
And how do you determine when
is the right time to do so?
>> So first is most times people
see the empty part of a glass.
At times,
people see also the full part of a glass.
You would always have difficulties and
challenges in almost
every sector,
especially countries you want to go into.
So when we decided to expand into Africa,
the story was first,
we thought that we had mastered
the act of serving customers,
because that's what banking is about.
Banking is about serving your customers,
all of our customers, customers,
customers.
And realizing that to
serve your customers,
you must have a mobilized
workforce that is aligned with
those mission and
vision that you see for the group.
So we felt, looking at the African
landscape, that we had opportunities.
Nigeria remains the largest
economy in Africa and
we thought that the level of banking or
service support was very high, and
that we should leverage this and
spread across the continent.
And we had to decide which
country should we go to?
How do we decide the country and
macroeconomic stability, policies, etc?
Foreign exchange policies,
ease of doing business in countries,
taxation policies in countries.
And the demographic of countries
because we were quite upset that we
would like to support small and
medium scale enterprises.
That is the bedrock of United Bank for
Africa.
So based on that,
we came up with 30 countries that
met the internal criteria we set up.
We developed what we
call the UBA Red Book,
how wanted to expand in Africa,
issue to consider, etc.
But in all of those issues,
the ease of doing business in
countries was very critical.
The population was also important.
The GDP of countries income
per capita was important,
ease of finding the right human
capital to work with because,
again, it's a people business, so
that was very important to us.
And we came up with all of this,
we now tiered it.
Well, we developed what we call
the three-tier strategic intent.
Tier one was we wanted
to be strong in Nigeria.
Tier two, be a leading Pan African bank.
And tier three, having presence
in global financial centers,
which is why we start with London,
Paris, New York, Dubai.
It's all part of our
three-tier strategic intent.
The second one, therefore,
was orchestrating our expansion in Africa.
And on that, was what strategy do we do?
A conduit strategy or not, pass through or
have presence in countries.
And we decided that we needed
to have presence in countries.
And next was, okay,
let's tier the countries.
Again, we use GDP, that's what
we use in tiering the countries.
I would say it really.
Greenfield, brownfield, acquisition,
mergers, how do you want to grow?
We decided that we do
a combination of both.
So in the countries we went to,
some countries we acquired banks,
some we merged, and
some we said okay, greenfield.
And the journey so far so good.
Today, United bank for
Africa serves over 35 million
customers in Africa and
we're still growing.
We're helping to simplify
payments on the continent.
We're helping to orchestrate
trade transactions,
intra-Africa trade transactions.
Prior to this time, Africa did not
trade with and amongst itself.
We believe the reason Africa didn't
do this is because payment issues,
because of infrastructure,
even transportation infrastructure.
And also making sure we support and
capacitize small or
medium scale enterprise to grow.
So UBA has done quite a bit in this space.
And most importantly, financial inclusion.
We're trying to make sure that everyone,
a continent with over
one billion people,
the banking population is not so high.
So to us, it's not just about
offering banking services
It's about what we call democratization
of access to financial services.
It's about financial inclusion.
So I'm making sure that almost everyone
in markets where we're put in,
have access to banking facilities,
banking services.
And that's why in some
countries was spearheaded and
pioneered opening of bank
account zero balances.
Because what's important to us
is to be able to attract people.
We believe that Africa will have
informal economy that is very large.
And all of us should be involved in
trying to formalize the informal economy.
And this is one of the ways we're doing
so, through our banking services.
In other areas of operation and
as a group we to try to do the same thing.
What we do at the Tony Elumelu Foundation
is all again about helping to develop
the continent, financial empowerment,
taking opportunities to people,
irrespective of your cadre,
irrespective of your level in society,
irrespective of where you live,
whether you're in urban or rural areas.
So those are things we need to keep doing
to create a more inclusive society,
especially in Africa.
>> You alluded to this
a little bit earlier.
There's a lot of innovation happening
in the financial services industry,
a lot of tech disruptors, and many of
which are working towards that goal of
democratizing access
to financial services.
From your position as CEO and
now chairman of United Bank of Africa,
how do you see the company collaborating,
or
even competing with some
of these disruptors?
Particularly thinking about new
technologies like cryptocurrencies,
peer-to-peer payments, etc.?
>> First is, I was CEO of UBA,
the Chief Executive Officer
of United Bank of Africa
about 12 years ago.
[LAUGH] So today,
I don't see myself as a banker,
per se,
I'm an investor that invests in banking,
in helping to improve access to
electricity on the continent.
A critical resource deficit on
the continent that's important to
preach if we must leapfrog and
move the continent to where it should be.
Investors in healthcare sector,
we have realized that
indeed health is wealth.
If the pandemic taught us one thing,
it is about prioritizing health and
realizing that what the world couldn't do,
health or lack of it can do.
Who would have thought that the entire
world would go into a lockdown mode?
I never thought that could
happen in my lifetime.
So we're invested in that sector.
We're invested in energy,
the full energy chain.
Because again, for a continent like
Africa, it's critical for us for growth.
So for us or for me, at this point
in time, not so much of a banker.
However, as a group,
we realize the importance of technology.
The digital disruption that
we see in the world is real.
And in Africa, in particular,
thanks to the population of our continent,
we know that we have to catch up.
If you don't catch up,
we're going to lag behind.
For businesses and
businesses we're associated with,
the United Bank of Africa and
other businesses, digital adoption
is critical for our service delivery,
for everything that we do.
In the payment space, we lead in
the payment space through digitization,
through adoption,
partnership with FinTech and all kinds,
just to make sure that we're
able to serve our customers.
Today's customers, they don't need a bank.
They just need a facilitator for payments.
They need a facilitator that
follows their lifestyle.
And banking is changing.
It's changing from the way we used
to know banking so many years ago.
Today you can sit in your house, in fact,
I tell you, at United Bank of Africa,
I told you earlier that we
have 35 million customers.
A few years ago,
2005 when we did the major case, and
that was by United Bank for Africa,
all of 2004 UBA celebrated,
we were the first bank in Nigeria
to have 32 ATMs [LAUGH] 32 ATMs.
And I love Nigeria.
I did a major marketing to have 32 ATMs.
And then the first bank also
to pay out of 1 billion Naira,
our local currency, billion Naira in cash.
Then let's just sat 200 Naira
per dollar in cash, today.
And then, then, 97% of our customer
transactions occurred in the banking hall.
Today, UBA opens about
500,000 accounts every month.
And these accounts, 95% are opened
online, not in the banking hall.
Number two, transaction count.
We have over 98% of our
customer transaction
now occurring online,
not in banking hall, again.
In terms of ATMs,
UBA alone, just UBA alone,
has close of 4,000 ATMs in Nigeria,
all from 32 ATMs.
>> [CROSSTALK]
>> I've got POSs, uncountable,
there was no POS before.
So things have changed and
bandwidth will change further.
The technology is
disrupting a lot of things,
not just in the US, not in the West,
but everywhere, everywhere.
Even healthcare, in our healthcare
sector today healthcare can
be delivered digitally online,
and everything.
So we live in a new world and
everyone of us is adopting and
adapting faster to the new world or
we'll be left behind.
>> You mentioned energy a little earlier,
which makes me nervous because it
seems as though you're reading my mind,
because that's where I want to go next.
Last year the Africa Energy Chamber
recognized you as one of the 25 most
influential individuals in
shaping Africa's energy sector.
I'm curious to know, especially knowing
that at Stanford, sustainability and
renewable energy, and energy more broadly
is a really important subject that gets
studied here and talked about a lot.
What are the most pressing issues and
solutions being discussed right now
as it relates to energy in Africa?
And also I would love to know a little bit
more about the work that you're doing,
I believe through Transcorp,
to address this.
>> So access to electricity
is extremely poor in Africa.
Less than 35% of our people have access
to reliable electricity on the continent.
This is a continent of young people.
Over 700 million people
are young on the continent,
under the age of 30, and yet access
to electricity is almost impossible.
These young ones are in
a very competitive world.
They're going to compete
with children who are used
to 24/7 uninterrupted electricity supply.
So the world we see ahead is actually
frightening because the divide
we want to breach is not the case
happening in the digital space,
is not happening because of access,
lack of access to reliable source
of energy on the continent.
And from the work we do at
the Tony Elumelu Foundation,
from our close interaction with
young Africans, male, female,
we know, we can tell, we see,
we hear, listen to them.
That access to electricity
is a major hindrance,
constraint on their ability to succeed.
I'm sure at Stanford,
you might have seen this in your
business research studies,
that most small and
medium scale enterprises on
the continent die, they don't succeed.
And single most important factor for
this due to poor access to electricity.
So to us as a group,
we believe in the concept and
philosophy of africapitalism,
which is a call on the private
sector to play some role in
developing our continent.
It's a realization that the private
sector has a role to play in
developing the continent.
And in practicalizing this,
and not just speaking to it,
we decided that the power
sector was critical for
us to invest in as we mobilize
resources and invest in this space.
Today, we have capacity to generate
about 2000 megawatts of electricity.
But we have some other hindrances like
gas supply and grid connectivity.
So we're able to generate about 700
megawatts out of the capacity of 2,000.
But we're happy that we're
playing a key role in this area.
But my message always has been to
investors, we've been on this trip,
we started from Washington,
we've been to New York.
We interacted a lot with
University of New York.
We were in LA,
we attended the McCain Institute,
which had a gathering of global
asset managers and former interns.
My message has been consistent.
We have opportunities in Africa.
There's huge opportunities in Africa,
a huge population.
Income per capita is improving, and
we lack access to electricity
on the continent.
So as the world mobilizes towards
a more inclusive society,
right, the world mobilizes
to a more prosperous
world, I always like to remind people that
we cannot have that prosperity
across the world if we will not deal
with the issue of access to
electricity on the African continent.
The reason we have youth unemployment
in Africa is attributable to this.
The reason we have youth restiveness
The reason some embrace extremism
is attributable to this.
In fact, government's ability to fight
extremism is also limited by this.
So, at times you see communities and
large spaces that do not feel
any impact of government or
society because no access to electricity.
So it's a major for me,
it's not just an investment.
A commercial investment is
what we should be doing in
the 21st century to help
improve access to electricity.
And yeah, I can never shout or
say it enough.
And I want to have more people
in this crusade that all of us,
those who have capital,
should look at investing in Africa.
There are opportunities there.
And those who have voices,
let's keep shouting to attract attention.
And those who have the focus, so
that collectively all of us can
make a difference in the Africa.
>> I want to stay a little bit,
I want to spend some time on what you
mentioned earlier, Africapitalism.
Which you are known across Nigeria and
other countries as well as being a strong
proponent of, you've detailed here.
I am curious to know why you believe
that Africa needs to take a unique
approach to capitalism.
>> Well,
it's not a unique approach to capitalism,
per se, it's for me realization.
Okay, so at times, there's this
entitlement mentality that people have,
okay?
We should be helped, we should be
supported, we should be developed.
Well, for Christ sake, I mean,
it can't be like that forever.
We need to help ourselves too.
So it's realization that call.
The private sector is growing.
We need government to prioritize it,
we need government to create the right
environment for
private sector to keep doing well.
But the private sector
also must be sensible and
reasonable and
conscientious in how we do things, okay?
We should invest in a manner that
helps to catalyze prosperity.
We should invest in a manner that helps
to create social equity, social wealth.
We should invest in a manner that
helps to create inclusiveness.
So, this is not just about a new
form of capitalism or the other,
it's more about the fact that
the private sector should play a role in
helping to develop the continent.
And let's stop blaming others for
our woes.
Let's stop blaming others for everything.
Let's lead and hopefully they follow.
And I've seen it happen.
In some of the investment we have made,
we did not invest all the capital assets,
we reached out.
I will say that the world we live in
is becoming highly interdependent, and
people are also beginning to listen,
especially if we show good example.
So it's a call on all of
us of whether in Africa or
outside the world,
that we all have a role to play.
In advanced society again,
the meeting I attended earlier,
it all had different names today.
Patient capital, impact investing,
shared prosperity, mutual destinies.
We just need to invest in a manner that's
not just about profits for the investors.
We should invest in a manner that
creates mutual benefits for everyone,
for the investors, for communities where
you do business in, for society at large.
The fact that we do what we do at the Tony
Elumelu Foundation, committing 100 million
US dollars to supporting of entrepreneurs
is not because we have so much money.
But we also know that some of the basic
needs we want to have are provided.
So it's not about what we
have in the bank account.
It is about that in the in the big eye.
Can we take a part of it and
share, not for
me not to share in the manner that creates
a dependency, perpetual dependency, no.
In a manner that makes you,
stand on your own, makes you self reliant.
And so when we, say we'll give non
refundable seed capital of $5,000.
And when we do so, to date over 16,000
Africans have benefited from that program.
It is not encouraged laziness, no,
more we know when San Francisco
were in tech environment.
We know some started with less than
$5,000 but today they've grown big.
So we just want to give young
Africans access, opportunity to prove
their concept, and then let others see
them as good accommodators in them.
So we need all the privacy discipline.
We need everyone in the private sector
looking at critical sector today we talked
I just spoke about electricity.
Instead of people giving their monies and
backpackers abroad.
Why did you bring your money to
invest in letraset on the continent?
You make more money by, you also
impact society in a more positive way.
There is yet the essence of is so,
we will need more, private sector leaders,
showing the way, but we need also
our public sector leaders creating
the right environment that will
enable the private sector to do.
And we need friends of Africa,
development partners also
begin to look at how our data when
are they engaged I had to give
the first century with the aim
to create self-reliance and
independence rather than perpetuating
the syndrome of dependence.
>> Now, Tony, typically when people
retire from very high stress jobs,
such as being the CEO, one of the largest
banks in Africa, they take a vacation.
You instead decided to found
a company Aeris Holding, and
also the foundation
that you've alluded to.
I'm curious, this was back,
this was a few years ago.
I'm curious about what you saw happening,
like in Nigeria or
beyond that at that time.
Drug that was the impetus for
you to develop this foundation.
>> We did two things,
when I retired in 2010,
12 years ago,
we decided to create a family office,
which was to some extent Novem
in other parts of the world.
And we'll say the family office
will be quite catalytic,
in the kind of investment that will make,
hence this philosophy of Afro capitalism.
So as audience is epitone and
this home of overall
group investment philosophy
of Africa policy.
And decided the sector's
consider very important,
that we have to move the needle power.
With Nigeria and Africa is endowed
with a lot of sources, yet
we do not have the ability to process all
of this, and convert them to the state.
So that they can be calm valuable,
to people so
said NH from integrator point of view and
I call the value chains.
Looked at healthcare sector,
I will say health is It's important
that we need to invest in
the healthcare sector.
So these were the key of course, estate
important in Africa and hospitality, okay.
Hospitality, if you want to
grow a country and economy,
transportation and
hospitality critical for this.
So those are the things we decided to
do at the time the motivation was,
to help drive our philosophy further.
By all important to help
manage the investments, and
we wanted to push our Exodus as the go
to investment partners on the continent.
We wanted help to attract investment,
to the continent, and so
far, so good on that.
And the other thing we did
the second thing was the foundation.
I thought that my story has been
one of this element of luck,
in my story, this element of being at
the right place at the right time.
And I wasn't the most
intelligent in my class and
also, I wasn't the most hardworking
my certain people I knew.
And therefore there was
a lock in it that was and
I thought, I had risen very
rapidly don't question and
I thought it was time to commit
this second phase of my life.
To have into impact humanity,
tap into to democratize
dialogue that I had
growing up to help expand
access to opportunities, to help people.
I mean, I talk about parents, I set still
have to remember small scale entrepreneur,
not the kind of big
entrepreneur that I see.
So I was not like, a son of any
known families so to speak,
just regular family person.
And so I've been inspired by what
I see around the world, look at,
Steve Jobs, for instance,
and his background.
And I asked myself see Joe were an African
if it was an African in Nigeria,
would you have been able to succeed?
At this scale and magnitude I succeeded.
I mean, long after deat as
a company is funded first
across 1 trillion in market cap,
and all recently so
it's all of you that drove me to say no.
It will be, an unfortunate I don't
know what I would say to God,
if I do not create or
have to create more email list on
the continent of our kind first instance.
And that was what drove, my wife and
I at the time to decide
that if you commit $100 M.
To helping, to identify, support, and
empower, the generation
of African leaders and
to do it at the scale and magnitude,
that's never been done before.
Given that we do business in many
African countries with distribution or
Wi Fi Nigeria, issue about Africa,
given that we know that poverty anywhere
is a threat, all of us everywhere,
would say to make sure that it's broader.
So that is why We started
the Tony Elumelu foundation.
So the motivation for
starting the Tony Elumelu Foundation,
is to help democratize, lock,
create access to people.
Whether or
not you big match if you have ideas,
you are enthusiastic, you are committed,
you are ambitious, apply it,
and you set diagnostic.
I will give you an opportunity.
So when I look back today,
I see that as a major,
major achievement, what we have done,
the happiness I see on the faces of
these young Africans, gives me good.
>> So my final question for you.
You seem to be a nation in and
of yourself through the foundation.
You've worked with local governments
international governing bodies to help
move capital where it's most needed.
And so I'm sure you've heard it asked many
times before Nigeria is now it's in its
election season.
I will join the chorus.
Why aren't you running for President?
>> [LAUGH] [LAUGH] I didn't
see that coming,
I think first is
When I look around I
know the potential that
we'll have as a continent and as a people.
I see opportunities,
I know that life can be a lot better for
people often times you feel the urge to,
Show interest in how we're governed or
how things happen.
By soon also realize that
because I've never been selfish,
because I've never been self centered,
because never been to
me that must be Tony.
I say to myself,
there are other good people capable people
who are in the race who
are showing interest.
Why don't you support them and
share with them what you
think should be the right
thing in terms of leadership,
in terms of governance,
in the 21st century Africa,
wherever was suffering
according to suffer so much.
I realize also that all of us
cannot be in the political space.
By no way that evil succeeds or
tries in the world when
good people keep quiet
So I said to myself, just the way
am committed to entrepreneurship,
the way am committed to helping
to empower young Africans.
We should support emergence, castration or
good governance across the continent,
because I think that is
what I said was Africans.
So for me, Japan, Nigeria,
is many countries,
many countries on the continent.
So, I am interested in good governance.
And I know that what we preach and
advocacy and everything we do try to
encourage young people will not
succeed in the political space if
leadership is not good So mine is for
to continue to encourage
the evolution of the political
process that we want
through a good leadership.
And to ensure that our leaders stay
accountable that process is not there yet,
but we are working
together against one area.
When I was in Washington,
I said to put good leadership here too,
that it should be a concerted effort to
think encouraged people on the continent
to do what is right, even as we also
on the continent continue to speak
out on good governance and accountability
>> Thank you so
much Tony that was amazing and
typically we like to close with
a lightning round of questions, so I have
four for you and I'm going to say them and
you have to answer as quickly as possible,
hence, the lightning part.
So outside of aside from Palo Alto,
California,
what's your favorite place to visit?
>> I did that.
Sorry
>> What's your favorite place to
travel to.
>> Assa?
I just came from LA Los Angeles I
love Los Angeles
>> More than San Francisco
>> No you do some more
[LAUGH]
>> Now with Nigeria out of the World Cup
who are you rooting for.
>> Wow [LAUGH] even my voice they
were like crying when they drop.
I think Nigeria is, Senegal.
>> Okay, that's good safe choice.
>> Senegal.
>> What's-
>> Who's from it Senegal here?
[LAUGH] What is your favorite Wizkid song?
>> Hit song?
>> What's your favorite Wizkid?
>> Wizkid song?
[LAUGH] you dont know that.
>> I dont know.
>> Who has a iphone here?
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
last question,
what are you most grateful for?
>> I'm grateful to go for
my wife and family and children.
I think, you can't do it live you
don't have a home that's at peace.
I do have a very peaceful area for
center, so I'm grateful to go for that.
>> Thank you so
much [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]